good evening everyone
welcome to today's meeting of the panel
if you have any technical difficulties
during the meeting then please contact
the democratic services officer on call
who will attempt to assist you today's
officer on call is katie brewer
and her number is 577046
microphones must only be on if the
participant has been granted permission
to speak
to gain my permission to speak please
indicate on the chat and i will make a
note and call you when it's your turn
with everyone present please ensure that
their mobile phones are turned to silent
and that they are not used to make or
receive phone calls whilst the meeting
is in progress
please also refrain from checking emails
and ensure that you're in a quiet room
for the duration of the meeting
please note this meeting is being live
streamed for members of the public
the meeting will also be recorded and
will subsequently be broadcast on the
internet
please can i ask members of the panel to
confirm that they are present at the
meeting when i read out your name
councillor boyd
councilor coleman cook president chair
councillor curry present chair
councillor hopkinson
council hopkinson
no councillor huxley president chair
councillor keane president chair
councillor pat moore present chair
council paul moore present chair
councillor linda piper
here chair thank you councillor ratigan
here
scott i know he's not here he's he sent
his apologies
okay i've received the following request
to speak under 20.1
which is council of ghana on agenda item
seven
are there any other members wishing to
speak under 20.1
all right hello councillor before jess i
am here um and just to let you know
um councillor oppa is trying to get in
he's having some problems so i've given
him um
the number of katie to give her a call
so i hope that you'll enjoy
it soon lovely thank you thank you
okay uh
apologies for absence uh the i've
finally received the one which is from
councillor scott have there been any
others charles
yes yes chair i have received apologies
from councillor hopkinson
okay is he not joining us at all no i
don't think he will be tonight
okay all right thanks council curry
thank you
uh agenda item two declarations of
interest
are there any declarations of interest
i can't see anyone indicating so i'll
take that as a no
gender item three to approve the minutes
of the overview and scrutiny panel
meeting held on the 18th of february
2021
a copy of which was attached to the
agenda pack could i have a proposal and
a seconder for those please
i'll propose that chair council coleman
cook thank you
second to please i'll second that chair
councillor carrie thank you very much
unless i hear any objection i'll take
those minutes as approved
gender item 4 minutes of an
extraordinary meeting
this is to approve the minutes of the
extraordinary meeting of the ovu and
scrutiny panel held on the 17th of march
2021
copy of which was attached to the agenda
pack could i please have a proposal for
those please
i'll i'll propose that uh chat to
cameron thank you council curry second
i'll second that chair brilliant thank
you very much
unless i hear any objection i will take
those as approved
thank you agenda item
five domestic violence in thanet how
kent police are addressing the issue
i'd now like to welcome to the meeting
chief inspector rhiannon pepper
to make a presentation
thank you so much um thank you so much
for inviting me
so i was asked today following our last
meeting just talk a bit about
the domestic violence and domestic abuse
in thanet
obviously it's something i am really
passionate about and when i took over in
november it was an area that
i thought really does need a lot of
scrutiny so for those of you that aren't
aware
we have a dedicated specialist officers
that deal with domestic abuse
i think that's really important in the
same way that we have it for hate crimes
and the same way that we have it for
rapes
to have that specialism and that
overview and it's to make sure
that we have the best person looking
into the offences because quite a lot of
time it is a one-on-one offence
and it's going to take a lot to get the
trust of the victim
so i'll briefly go through this and then
i'll talk about what i'm doing in thanet
so
domestic abuse recorded crime if you
have a look you can see we had a
significant jump last year
11.8 jump in the recorded crime of
domestic abuse
again if you look at the charts you'll
see that september august september
is quite often a time that we see an
increase
there are other times that we know we'll
see an increase in domestic abuse so we
know over christmas we'll see an
increase
we know during the football we will see
an increase and we can plan for that
so and again we'll come more into what
our plans are and how we're dealing with
that
so the next slide is recorded arrests
and again you can see over the role in
three years
we've jumped up with our arrest rate and
that is really critical
because we have to show that we are
taking this seriously
and when it's proportionate and
necessary to rest we must be doing that
and that is
absolutely drilled into our offices
at all levels regardless of if their
first response if the cid if they're the
victim investigation team which
deals with domestic abuse and the reason
it's really important to get those
arrests
is to get that separation to allow us
time to go and speak to the victim
without the offended presence and again
once i start talking about the plans
i'll explain again why that is so
critical for us to be able to do that
if we have a look at recorded charges
you'll see again we have seen a huge
jump in our recorded charges
this year we have seen a real
significant
change towards our charge rate because
we are putting the investment in it
we're putting the
people in to do the investigations but
more importantly we are changing the
culture
and culture doesn't change quickly so
when i talk about changing the culture
looks across all different forces to
have a look at domestic abuse how it's
been dealing with it um what is the best
way to get those prosecutions
and what was really clear is that when
we look at our sister force essex
the way they approached it was different
to the way we approached it in kent and
certainly within than it
so from november we started it's called
the eight point plan
but the main crux of this is that you
won't say
when you attend can i take a statement
when you attend
domestic abuse you will say i am here to
take a statement from you
regarding what has just happened you're
taking the ownership away from the
victim
you are telling them i am going to take
this from you this is really important
i need to get the best evidence so
that's the first one
the second big change is that we now
leave an officer with the victim
as i'm sure you're all aware with the
call command coming in a lot of the time
we go
we arrest the vic we arrest the offender
we take them back to custody and then
it's probably two to three hours before
you go back
get back to the victim by which point a
lot of the time they've normalized
behavior the offender's gone
they are now in a safer place and they
don't want to engage with us
and so we've seen a real change by
leaving the officer there
getting that first evidential the
statements making sure the body warns on
so we can record all the injuries any
damage
getting that really good evidential
capture and that's made a massive change
as well
because it just shows we are taking this
importantly and
we're not allowing them to normalize
we're not allowing them once the
offender's gone to go
okay that's fine they're out the house i
don't need to worry about it
we're getting getting them and getting
the best evidence we can at the time
so the charge rate is on the up
if we have a look at the arrest rates
you'll see we're probably mid but you
see the jump so
we are looking about 42 of all domestic
abuse
that we attend we arrest the ones that
we don't arrest there's a good reason
now there is so much scrutiny i've put
so much scrutiny in this
so in my morning meetings i will go
through every single domestic abuse that
we've attended in the last 24 hours
and i'll look what's been arrested what
hasn't been arrested and if there hasn't
been arrest
then must be a rationale so that i can
understand why there hasn't been an
arrest and sometimes
it is completely appropriate not to
arrest
but the times where i've looked through
and i don't think it's appropriate the
first thing i do is go back to inspector
i will have a body warm video check
and i'll say what have they said to that
victim
why haven't we arrested why is there not
a statement
on a weekly meeting with my inspectors
we will look through domestic abuse is
part of the
process and i'll say talk me through i
want to know
the body-worn video checks that you as
inspectors have done on your staff
to make sure that we are going across
there and treating those victims
correctly making sure that when the
officers are attending they are taking
it seriously
they are getting that buying and
confidence from those victims and we
have those weekly checks in place
again when we look at the charge rates
you'll see from last year 3.3
it has jumped to 6.4 that is a
significant
jump with charges it's still not as far
as still not as high as i want and we
are again continuing to make progress
but it is putting that um
focus on domestic abuse which is
required
the next one is a d.a intimate breakdown
that's just explaining
when we say intimate that is intimate
partners or ex-partners
so you have intimate and non-intimate so
none intimate might be a mother and a
son
or two brothers they will go into the
non-intimate intimate is
partners or ex partners and again if you
look through you'll see the breakdown
we will generally have between 72 and 76
are going to be intimate d a that we
attend
and the last one and then i'll just talk
through a bit what we're doing
is repeat victims and this is the key
for me
because as you look down you can see
thanit disproportionately
has more six to ten reports over ten
reports we have
more repeat victims in thanet and i want
to know why that is
is it because we're not getting the
confidence of the victim at the first
one
is it because we're not getting the
buy-in so again with the specialist
teams
and the local police officers and our
community
um safety unit we're trying to do visits
on those repeat victims it's
trying to build up their confidence one
officer continually
speaking with that victim to get them to
trust them to get them to actually
engage
and to try and break down that offending
pattern and there's other things
i've been looking at and implemented so
drug testing on arrival
underutilized so drug testing on arrival
is really important i think because
there are certain crimes that you can
automatically do it for but an inspector
and above
can do it for other offenses so our
repeat offenders
the ones that we know have got a drug
problem we need to be drug tested on
arrival because then we can put a
positive obligation on them
to go and get help now the best case
scenario is that help works and we can
break that fending pattern
the worst case scenario is they don't go
for that help but actually by them not
engaging
we are building a better picture when we
take them to court to say
this is what we are trying to break this
pattern they are not engaging and we are
more likely to get
a successful outcome at court which is
really important
we've just had um alcohol um testing as
well that's literally just come out
and again i'm talking with the
vulnerability teams around where we know
alcohol plays a big part in these
offending
we need to be putting alcohol tags on
the offenders we
really need to be breaking down over 10
reports
17 people that 17 people that we're
saying are constantly
suffering we need to be breaking this
down and getting better at it
so i talk quickly about the eight point
plan i say
the real change here is the difference
that we've had with our local officers
our first responders and it's the why
when you ask somebody to do something
they will do it but you must explain the
why and actually sitting down going to
the briefings explaining
that if you take this seriously if you
give them confidence in the first
instance if you get that best evidence
they will engage with us and we are
likely to get successful prosecution
so it's the retraining in and it has
worked the culture has changed
and it's shown by our arrest rate and
it's shown by our charge rate
but there's still work to do as i say my
main focus at the moment is around those
repeat victims
is how we can engage with them how we
can look
at breaking that pattern that behavior
so something i'm really passionate about
we are heading in the right direction
there's a lot more that we need to do i
am acutely aware of that
but as a start in the last six months i
certainly think we've made some great
strides not only culturally
but also with our arrest rates and with
our charge rates into making the dent in
this
thank you okay thank you very much for
that
members questions comments
thank you i mean it sounds really good
what you're doing
um i just wanted to go back to i think
it was the
the first slide and i think it was
arrests
where in the 19 to 20 year there were
130
in than it and 20 to 21 there were 278
now i know you've said about um you know
that you're doing this work so
that presumably would have increased
that anyway but i just wondered if you
thought there was any other
circumstances behind such a big increase
i think because we've we've put the
focus and the vulnerability
investigation teams um has really put
the focus
on domestic abuse and as part of kent
police it has
an area that we need to improve on and
so by raising that understanding by
raising that awareness
and by explaining we we take positive
action and
that is the officers that are coming in
their training
it is absolutely embedded in them that
we will take positive action
unless there is a a really discerning
reason why not
so the arrest rate i'm glad to see it
rising and i still like to see it rise a
little bit more
as i say i look through this every day
and there's sometimes ones where i go i
think we could have done more on that
one
so i think it is that change that we
will take positive action
unless there is a real reason why we're
not going to and then it has to be
evidenced
does that make sense yeah thank you
okay uh council curry
uh hello they
increasingly abuse um
i wonder whether the uh the increases
have been in particular areas
in fanny or has the increase been
um across the aisle thank you
i haven't got the break down here but i
haven't had a look through it and
i say it paying quite keen ascension to
it since i've been here in november
it is very widespread so um
there might be certain demographic areas
that you think would have a higher
rate and that's just not the case
domestic abuse is everywhere
um through all our communities
regardless okay thank you
councillor boyd thank you chair
um thank you for your presentation it's
really good to see the chargements
and how we're doing quite well in
comparison to the rest of the county
um it was just more of a question around
is this type of domestic abuse more the
physical
side of things or how you see more of a
trending increase of
um coercive control emotional blackmail
those kind of things so i think there's
often a misconception that domestic
abuse is just
a physical and assault so i just wonder
whether you have seen cases because
obviously they are probably quite more
difficult to prosecute
and evidence so i just wondered if
there's any work around that area of
domestic abuse
there is some work i don't have the data
with me now you are right we are seeing
more cursive
control and behavior
the majority of these will have
a assault base to them be it's a common
salt
or hiat but we are certainly seeing a
rise in
rehearsal controlling value it's like
easy for me to say
um but again that that's to do with the
training again with the police officers
so they can pick it up
whereas before it wasn't being recorded
now officers are picking this up and
recording this and understanding this is
actually
as important and we need to deal with
this as robustly as we would do if
somebody had a physical injury
so yeah we are seeing that trend
increasing
well i can't see any other members at
the moment i've got a couple of
questions
um the first is i think you said that uh
the charge rate which is around about
six percent you were
a bit disappointed with that so a couple
of questions around that
first is um what do you think inhibits
the charge rate
and is the implication of your
disappointment that
charging is a major factor in stopping
repeat behavior
okay i'll go with the first one
uh first question first now i think
a big inhibitor is the fear of
the repercussions the fear of the
offender
i think a big change is where we've sat
there and immediately whilst it's fresh
in their mind before they have a chance
to normalize them i keep saying this
because that hour or two that we leave
with the offender
they calm down they normalize what has
happened so
actually getting that account straight
away
i think has made a big difference to the
way that we deal with it certainly
getting those statements
over 75 percent now of the calls we
attend we get a statement straight away
and those we don't get a statement
we look at and it is not through lack of
trying is that
they do not want to engage with us on
that occasion and the only thing we can
do there
is to then do a follow-up visit to try
and get them to engage at a later
time so i think the inhibitor
is the engagement with the officers
because of the fear
of what's going to happen next how's
this going to affect me
and it is trying to break down that
cycle uh the second sorry if you throw
the second question again please
um well yeah the first one was what
inhibits the charge right and the second
one was whether you thought that
um charging was a major factor in
stopping repeat
offending i think there's a lot of
factors that need to be
explored around um stopping that
repeat offending i think charges do play
um a part especially in those
serial offenders that are constantly
doing it be it with the same partner be
it with different partners i think
that does play a part but equally i
really do think
the help around the drug testing the
help around the alcohol the factors that
are causing them
to behave in that manner so the anger
management
i think they equally are as important um
taking those steps with the offender to
look at their behavior
and their patterning and how we can
break that down
thank you uh councillor boyd you wanted
to come back
yes thank you and it was just uh another
thing i was watching
well half watching brookie telly um
yesterday morning and there was a piece
around vanessa
goose on it and i don't know where it
was but they were basically training up
plumbers
and people that visit homes to be aware
of
you know marks on the walls or doors
where you know they've been locked in a
bathroom or you know
handles and i just wondered whether the
potential for future work between
yourself and
possibly penny and the community and
some
engagement with our local um
housing service providers people doing
utilities
and just to kind of get more awareness
because i presume you're quite um
restricted to you know neighbors hearing
stuff
or um as opposed to people actually
going to home so i just wondered whether
that was something an area you might
look into in the future i absolutely
love that idea i think that is
didn't see i think that is a cracking
idea um and it's
definitely something i'll take away and
then um link in with because
you're right it is a lot of time it's
not the victim that phones us it's a
third party
but by having people raising the
awareness same way we did the child
sexual exploitation making sure the
taxis that the doormen
that licensees were aware raising that
awareness means we are more likely to
get those early indications and reports
of where domestic abuse is taking place
so actually i really love that idea i
think that is a really
good idea and one that we can go forward
with
okay brilliant okay uh councillor keane
thank you a separate question um and
that was just
where there's young children present do
the police
automatically refer to social services
or is that a judgment call
um no while the children are present we
automatically
will do also that they're aware and then
we also refer locally to schools as well
so that head teachers are aware that
we've attended because obviously the
impact on that child
um the head teachers need to know what
is going on in their home life
because that could explain some of the
behavior in schools so we are very good
at making sure all our partners are kept
aware especially with children
voice of the child is really really key
um within kent police it's making sure
that we're listening and looking after
those children in those premises
that's great thank you okay
i can't see any other questions i i've
got one last one i mean that domestic
abuse is
uh i think in most people's minds it is
associated with
female victims but we know that you know
there are male victims
um do you have any sort of figures for
the split in senate
no i don't have the figures but you're
absolutely right there are
male victims um i don't have the figures
but again as i say because i go through
them
every morning i see the female-to-male
ratio is still
predominantly male against female but
there is certainly
um a percentage of male victims
and i think sometimes it's harder for
them to make that
call or have that conversation because
of the way society
looks at domestic abuse um and again
that's something we're trying to really
work with
with those males that have reported at
domestic abuse to make sure
that they've got the support they've got
the welfare um in place around them
okay thank you i hasten to add i wasn't
speaking from experience
um could i on behalf of the panel
can i thank you very much for the
presentation and and uh you're answering
the questions
and uh i mean it would be really good if
you could be a regular visitor i know
we've covered a couple of areas i know
there's other areas of policing that
members would be interested in
but certainly you know perhaps in the in
12 months time a follow-up on
what you did last time and this time
would i think be very helpful if you'd
be prepared to do that
absolutely um always happy always happy
to see us what we're doing in thanet
so if there are areas you want me to
discuss just let me know
and again i'm quite happy to come along
and talk about them
brilliant thank you very much indeed
thank you bye-bye
[Music]
right members moving on agenda item 6
memorial's working party update i call
upon councillor stuart piper chair of
the memorial's working party to give us
an update
thank you chair good evening everybody
there is a report attached for this item
which is
similar to
so he can make the final decision about
the application
in question historic england and the
secretary of state will apply the new
policy of
retain and explain meaning historic
statues will only be removed
in the most exceptional circumstances
i think the idea behind that chair is
probably self-explanatory it's designed
to stop knee-jerk reactions
such as we had not so long ago
with the memorial plaque in in broadcast
the secretary goes on to say what has
stood for generations should be
considered thoughtfully
not removed on a whim any removal should
require planning permission
and local people should have a chance to
be properly consulted
our policy in law will be clear that we
believe in explaining
and retaining heritage not tearing it
down
an important little footnote at the
bottom it says the new rules will also
apply to unlisted historic plaques
memorials and monuments which will also
require planning permission and historic
england
will be informed chair i haven't i
haven't had any further explanation
about
looking forward to proposals to erect
new statues or plaques and monuments but
i would imagine the planning
permission clauses would still apply but
i'm sure that our proper officer will
put that in the final report when it's
prepared for you thank you very much i
commend that to
members thank you thank you chairman
um members
um the proposal um is that
uh we should if you like uh
so than a lot of the correct
terminologies and perhaps charles can
help me out but we should sort of
suspend temporarily um the
activities of the working party uh
pending
the national legislation coming into
force
then you know bringing it back into
into action as soon as that happens but
by doing that that will give us the
opportunity
to run a very short review of something
else in the meantime which i think would
be
very good use of members times uh
chairman
are you happy with that yes
yes indeed okay thank you
members uh comments please
okay i i can't see anybody uh making
wanting to make any comments so
therefore
uh can i propose from the chair that we
do as i've just outlined that
we sort of temporarily spent suspend
activity of this working party
pending national legislation being
introduced
which will allow the panel to authorize
another piece of work in the short term
does that find a second or anywhere
i'll second that chair thank you caster
coleman cook
um members is that agreed
agreed i can see lots of nodding i can't
see anybody objecting so
i'll take that as agree thank you
members thank you very much
okay uh
agenda item seven planning enforcement
review
um this is a follow-up from the
item that we had in february when the
panel received a report from ian
livingston
i'd like to open this discussion um
by hoping that we can this afternoon
agree a way forward the
the proposal in general that i would
make is that
we would in fact set up a small
working party maybe six seven members
um with the idea that they would
actually
inform the review of the enforcement
protocol the planning department are
looking at at the moment
and that perhaps a single
meeting of that uh working party might
be sufficient to come up with
suggestions that could be brought back
to this panel
uh for par onward pass into the
executive so
i'll ask you to think about that for a
minute while i bring in councillor ghana
who wishes to speak under 20.1
thank you yeah thank you councillor
bayford
thank you and thank you members for
allowing me to speak at this meeting
i spoke at the last overview and
scrutiny meeting when planning
enforcement was discussed
asking for a scrutiny project to be
kicked off urgently
to conduct a proper open review into the
effectiveness of the informant
enforcement function within planning as
a whole
as a whole and to explore ways in which
it can be expanded and improved the main
reason i
think i thought and i still think this
is necessary
relates to the climate emergency we all
passed nearly two years ago now
a number of policy amendments have been
made to the local plan
to protect our natural environment and
enhance the biodiversity across the
district
many of these new policies will result
in planning applications being passed
with tougher climate emergency
biodiversity related conditions
it is vital that not only do we work
with developers
to make sure they understand what we
expect from them but also that we have
an enforcement function
that makes sure what they do that they
do what's expected
as it stands i do not believe that we
have an enforcement function equipped to
be able to do this
as is noted in the report before you the
enforcement team works
in a reactive rather than proactive way
on the whole
once a planning application is passed
developers are left to get on with it
and enforcement officers only get
involved if they receive a complaint
from a member of the public as is also
noted in the report
tdc's enforcement team of two
is the smallest in the county a thorough
review is needed to identify
ways in which the process can be
improved so that the effective
enforcement function we need can be put
in place
quickly the proposal for discussion this
evening
is i believe inadequate for two reasons
firstly the review team should be open
for contributions
from members of the public not just
concerned residents
but also representatives of the
development companies
who the enforcement team need to work
with
secondly if we really want this to be a
meaningful review
that will actually make a difference a
single meeting to review the planning
enforcement protocol with officers
isn't enough i would respectfully
suggest
that a team with a wider remit than that
is required
to include meeting with the planning
services manager
and planning enforcement officers to
understand and review current planning
enforcement protocols
and working practices and
inviting representatives of local
developers and concerned members of the
public
to meet with the team to discuss current
working practices
and explore ideas to improve the process
before proposing changes to improve the
process
with agreement from all of those
involved thank you
thank you councillor ghana members any
any comments from anyone
okay councillor kane yeah i
just wanted to say that i agree with
what council magana has said
i think a wider remit would be more
beneficial
i would also like to know more about how
other councils are dealing with this
because i do think
partly because of our small team but
that we do have particular problems here
in our
reactive approach thank you
okay a cancer roper
uh yes i would like to reiterate that
again that
and support councillor gardener that
having just two enforcement officers
is just nowhere near enough to keep on
top of all the problems that
that arise i seem to hear countless of
times when
enforcement officers just don't have the
time to do their job properly so it
really does need a
an in-depth review i feel thank you
okay um any other comments
um i've got um mr willis and mr porter
are present do either of you wish to
make any comment at this stage
and understand if you don't want to
um chairman would you mind if i make uh
a comment um
obviously it's for um members to
articulate and describe the terms of
reference
for for this action i think obviously
and i'm sure you will consider the
of the any kind of outcomes from any
review will need to take we'll need to
inevitably
take into account the availability of
resources to support
any kind of outcomes that
uh fall out of that and also it's about
managing expectations if there's a
suggestion
that we engage directly with the public
then
obviously that also has to be managed in
the sense of
understanding what resources would be
available to support any aspirations
that they may
they may be sharing and also i would
just raise the fact that
the time uh officer's time will need to
be taken into account in respect of
actually supporting
this review so we just need to be
mindful that we approach it in a
sensible manner because obviously
officers are already very busy but
appreciate the fact that members will
have
um a significant involvement in in doing
some of the
work or i'm assuming that members will
have an involvement in doing some of the
work
okay thank you um council huxley
thanks chair i'd just like to say i'd
like to be if you were going to set up a
subcommittee i'd like to be on that
the planning enforcement review isn't
just about new builds it's about
listed buildings in places like ramsgate
in the conservation areas so that's a
important part of it as well thanks
okay
okay um members i mean having listened
to council ghana
and well and other members obviously um
i think yeah the the valid points that
have been made
um the reason that um
we i was looking at a single meeting
review really was uh in
recognition of the scarcity of resource
and in fact taking advantage of the fact
that we were standing down the
memorial's working party but
um you know that that clearly may be a
fairly temporary thing
um so what i'd like members to think
about i've got a couple of other people
to come in in a minute
um but um what i'd like members to think
about
is whether we could run with the idea
of a single meeting
for a review which would be let's say
six or seven members from this committee
from this panel with uh appropriate
officers
um which has already been agreed in
principle
um by mr livingston he could support
that
but that the that review group
uh actually takes a wide view
and as it reports back to to the panel
if it does
think that an in-depth review would be
worthwhile
it could think about um how that might
operate
and bring those recommendations back
which would enable then
to set up a panel sorry a committee a
review committee
with perhaps a wider remit than i was
thinking of
in the first instance now council curry
you you've got your hand up
um you're muted counselor curry i think
dropped my hand and okay okay
from the top from the top again yeah
uh thanks chair um yeah i just got going
to say i think
panel members do hear from residents
and uh we can take residents concerns
forward i think
this is what gives scrutiny its value
and having a close connection with
residents and i think a a panel
would hear from residents and take their
concerns forward
and i do think a single meeting um would
take this forward
quicker than something that that took a
very long time
where we were talking to so many people
we've got bogged down
in in too many um proposals uh thank you
chair
thank you members
are there any other comments uh and if
not
uh can i take it that there's you know
that we would be
happy to start off with this single
meeting
it's quite a lot of nodding going on in
that case
uh could i ask for six or seven
volunteers please
ideally somebody from the planning at
least one person who's on the planning
committee would be useful
we've got councillor huxley
yes chair i'd be willing to be on that
cather coleman
although i'm not on the planning
committee i have done the training i
mean
it's essential that we've got both you
know some planners and some none yeah
okay i would chair
okay council rating yeah i would share
council paul moore paul moore yeah
i'd be happy to chat if you need one
more there
councillor curry okay i think uh
that's you know reasonable cross-section
um
i think i think that would be quite good
um
can i just start i mean uh councillor
roper
um we don't have a green party
representative on there i wonder if you
might be interested
thank you for the offer but i think i'm
going to have to decline it for personal
reasons
okay fair enough in which case um
we have a panel of uh or a
suggested review team of counselors
huxley coleman cook
council linda piper council ratigan
councillor paul moore
councillor curry so is that agreed
members
yeah can i just ask chief executive
you've heard the proposal um are you
comfortable with that
uh absolutely yeah thank you okay thank
you
members uh take that as agreed then
thank you very much
a gender item eight
right um impact of covered 19 on
businesses and communities in
oh sorry councillor kane sorry
didn't see you i just wanted to check on
my screen
counselor ghana looks like he's frozen
because i thought he might be interested
in being on the thing so
i didn't want him to miss out on his
opportunity if that was the case
uh the reason i didn't go to councillor
ghana was that it was a panel
it was a group drawn from this panel in
the first instance
oh i see yeah no i see yeah okay that's
fine thank you
i appreciate that hello councillor king
thank you very much okay
i would obviously would but okay
um uh councilloratigan um i think the
the
choice uh chair will be uh sorted out
actually at the meeting
okay um so
try again with agenda item eight
impact of covid19 on businesses and
communities in thanet
i'd now invite the chief executive to
share some ideas of how the panel
might approach this topic after that
perhaps we could have a bit of a
discussion about
a way we might see the way forward so
maddie over to you thank you very much
chair thank you
uh members i'm just going to take the
opportunity just to share with you
some things that um we have achieved uh
over the last year
in relation to our response to kovid 19
and then i've got
four options um that i'm going to
suggest
just to prompt a discussion uh it'll be
for you to decide which if any of those
or a variation of those you want you
want to take forward
but i just thought it was only right
really um
for all of us in tdc just to recognize
uh what we
what we have been doing over the past
year and this is just some of the
main things obviously it's not
everything um and i think we're all
accept that this year has been no longer
it's been unlike any other year
i mean obviously stanley is a busy time
at the best of places but i think we'd
all recognize that the challenges that
pandemic
uh has created this year were things
that we hadn't
uh anticipated however saying that
i think it's also fair to say that we
were actually actively
responding to the kobit 19 pandemic
before the first lockdown in march
and sometimes i think we forget about
that so
even before lockdown we have reviewed
and refreshed our business continuity
plans
uh in light of the uh emerging uh
crisis of covet 19. we'd already
provided capacity for home working
including training sessions and crib
sheets for
staff to enable them to access the
systems appropriately
we provided staff with regular updates
on the situation
including access to frequently asked
questions and we established an officer
group
including all senior management who met
regularly to review the situation
and make sure that we could respond to
take action
and then of course as we all know in
march or march the 23rd
came the national lockdown and which for
most industries
i guess this meant reduced work not
necessarily positive for them
but for us as a council and all of us as
a council that meant everyone's stepping
up
and actually working harder which
in itself is quite a challenge because
i'm sure you appreciate um we're not
we are quite lean as an organization
from a resource point of view
but within the first week we've managed
to reduce
we've dealt with reducing access to the
offices put in increased regimes and
hand
sanitizers established back office
support for those working from home such
as scanning and printing assistance
we closed off public spaces such as
playgrounds
we'd maintained our refuge collection
services
we'd allowed residents with parking
permits to park in council car parks
free of charge
and suspended parking charges for nhs
and social care workers
we set up and staffed a dedicated seven
day a week phone line to support our
vulnerable residents
to access services and supplies
we worked with partners to provide these
essential client
supplies because obviously we couldn't
do that solely ourselves so
we actually had to pull on our network
of community
and third sector organizations which
we'd already built
a very good relationship with we
contributed to a kent wide dedicated
business support line
and we provided temporary housing for
all those who were sleeping
rough at that time in addition to that
uh and as we move through the year we've
telephoned or visited over six
thousand extremely vulnerable residents
uh we have distributed ninety 000 pounds
worth of support for the extremely
vulnerable through food provision
we've distributed a hundred and thirteen
thousand pounds in support for those in
fuel poverty
we have issued warnings and prohibited
notices to business who flouted the
restrictions
uh we responded to the biggest influx of
visitors to the coast that we've seen in
a long time and you'll be aware of that
last summer
as part of our beach management uh plan
and again
obviously we're we've enhanced that for
this year
we increased the toilet cleaning regime
very importantly as a result of
maintaining
or trying to prevent outbreaks of kovid
19.
we were the first council in kent to
hold an online licensing subcommittee
we used innovative antibacterial
coatings on high touch points such as
parking machines
we temporarily closed roads to support
the reopening of high streets in july
we distributed discretionary test and
trace
support funding and we set up an
enforcement team specifically for covid
business enforcement and advice
we also provide a door knocking service
for track and trace and we continue
to do that as that's a requirement to
still
uh track uh any variations in covid19
we introduced covid wardens for the high
streets we created the beach management
plan which i've already mentioned
uh we provided sites for two driving
testing facilities
and kent's first walk-in testing site we
worked with partners to ensure our
homeless population had access
access to vaccines as a vulnerable group
and we've worked with local gps on how
to get vaccinations to the populations
where take-up was low on business
and on enforcement work we've responded
to 186 requests for advice and that's
since
january 2021 this year investigated at
89 complaints for non-compliance
undertaken
597 compliance visits given 57 informal
notices
and given 195 verbal warnings
we have four covered waters patrolling
the towns
and open spaces seven days a week
between the hours of 10 and six
and so far we've spoken to 851
businesses around guidance and
compliance advice
and 1861 members of the general public
i'm now going and in addition to that we
have also
of course been engaged in the kent wide
response
i've chaired the vulnerable people
community cell and
and other officers have been key players
in the enforcement environment and
finance sales
as well as as well as various other
tasks and finish groups
and of course we have engaged quite
significantly over the period
in our tactical command group meetings
and the strategic command group meetings
as i'm sure some of you appreciate they
were at one point happening on a daily
basis
including over christmas uh on that
point i am now just going to hand over
to tim willis who's just going to take
us through the grants
that he's been he and his team have been
busy working on overshoot him
thank you madeline thank you chair um
lots of numbers
so i'm going to try and keep this to as
few numbers as possible
um business grants and business rate
relief
we did start the the lock down last year
with business rates relief and we
administered 22 million pounds worth of
rates relief
in the retail hospitality and leisure
sector
um and then since then there's been sort
of three trenches of business grants
we started off last spring and summer
there's been two
types sort of mandatory and
discretionary
and the first trunks we distributed 34
million pounds worth of grants
which included 1.6 million of
discretionary grants
then during the lockdowns that started
in november there were a series of
payments
another two grant schemes and we've just
distributed about 20 million pounds 4
million pounds of which was
was discretionary that was called the
args
um and now we have um restart grants
which um were launched on the 9th of
april
which we estimate will be worth about 11
million and
we have another discretionary scheme
which we launched on the 12th of april
which we were expecting 750 000 for that
i think one of the key factors in
in relation to the the resourcing that's
been needed in terms of administration
for the council is that we've
administered all of the discretionary
schemes
and just the um the winter discretionary
scheme alone
has generated five and a half thousand
emails
to businesses and from businesses over
the last three months
for the for the arg team all of whom are
volunteers and do the work on top of
their day jobs
um so overall we've we've we've paid out
about 70 million pounds of grants to
businesses over the last year or so
and 22 million pounds of rate relief um
that's all i wanted to say
thank you chad right thank you can i
shall i present the four options uh i'm
just going to
if i may share just going to uh present
those just so that you've got them in
front of you if that's okay there's
nothing
sophisticated about them they're just my
thoughts just
to prompt a bit of discussion for you
okay i hope you can see those
um so we've got four options there
option one
is that uh we provide overview and
scrutiny with the presentation
on our response to kovic uh 19 between
march 2020 and march
2021 so a year or option two overview
and scrutiny could undertake
how did we do review of tdc's initial
response to the first lockdown
march 2020 to june 2020 including
continuation of service delivery and our
engagement with chem resilience form as
part of the emergency response
option three that you'll review how
we've managed the government's covered
funding streams including as
tim's obviously just shared business
grants
safely opening the high streets and the
clinically extreme
extremely vulnerable funds there are
some other
additional ancillary funds that we could
include in that as well
option four that you review our
community response during the pandemics
specifically the work of the community
hub
and our engagement with the voluntary
sector
okay thank you for that for four good
options
uh members comments please
you've stunned everybody into silence
maddie
well i mean you could we could start
with a a a
a a presentation to you um
on you know if if in a bit
which gives a bit more detail on the
things that we've sort of highlighted
um this evening and then take it from
there
it's um up to you really
how you want to take that forward okay
um check
go for option four please
four yeah because we've had
quite um in-depth um information
about the business grants um and
and i'd be interested to see what our
community
thinks about how the council
responded to the covid restrictions and
and all that they have done thank you
okay yeah i i'd agree with that i quite
quite like that i also quite like option
two which isn't very helpful i know
but um but we have a a proposal for
option four
does that find uh second or anywhere
i'll second that chair council
pastor paul moore okay um
okay so if we go for option four
um i suppose what we'd be looking for
is to bring to future meeting perhaps
the next meeting of overview and
scrutiny
uh some proposals of of how we might go
about that
and what would be the most effective
structure that
would you be able to organize that chief
exactly yeah
absolutely happy to do that i'll put
some terms of reference together and
some structure around that
and a proposal for how you might be
involved in that because i think
it's important that and clearly that's
what this is about making sure that
you're involved in that review
and uh depending on how that goes
there's no reason why we can't revisit
revisit option two once we've done
option four if you if you still want to
do that fine
okay members does that does that find
agreement
again i can't see any objections i can
see some nodding so
uh we'll bring back to the next meeting
of ovie and scrutiny some proposals for
how we go about
instituting option four so that agreed
right thank you very much members um
thank you tim and maddie for the
contributions there
gender item 9 review of isp work program
members are invited to comment on the
work program
and if there are no comments members are
requested to note the report
is that noted thank you
the gender item 10 forward plan an
exempt camp
cabinet report list for period 10th of
march to
31st of august 2021 unless there's
something from the plan that the panel
would wish to consider
members are asked to note the report
okay that's julie noted members officers
thank you very much for your time
i wish you good evening thank you very
much